er wird nicht nach kiew reisen das hat
scholz heute wie gesagt mitgeteilt er
sei unmittelbar vor dem krieg schon dort
gewesen und keiner telefoniere so viel
mit selen ski wr die ausladung
steinmeiers hat er zudem als irritierend
bezeichnet bei mir im studio es
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer glaubt sie
dass es da einen zusammenhang gibt also
wenn es die nicht geben würde dann würde
ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr jan
schäfer heißt natürlich gibt es den ganz
klar olaf scholz ist massiv verärgert
über diese ausladung die bundesregierung
vor allem die spd massiv verärgert und
man muss aber auf der seite immer wieder
sagen das was gestern von seiten der
ukraine was wir gehört haben dass unser
kollege paul ronzheimer da auch
zusammengetragen hat einstimmen das ist
natürlich das stimmungsbild was in kiew
herrscht dass das stimmungsbild was in
der regierung die sie lynskey herrschen
dort ist einfach die verärgerung über
steinmeier war über auch gerhard
schröder über den kurs der
bundesregierung in den vergangenen
jahren gerade von spd politikern einfach
so groß dass man dort auch das gefühl
hat durch diesen kurs dieses enge
partnerschaftliche verhältnis zwischen
deutschland und russland ist eigentlich
der angriff auf die ukraine mit möglich
gemacht worden und da ist es klar wenn
man in einem land wohnt ist überfallen
wird dann von russland dass man
entsprechend verärgert reagiert
stichwort s-klasse steinmeier und
schröder haben ihre russland freundliche
vergangenheit schon eingeholt wird
manuela schwesig die nächste sein also
man kann sagen dass manuela schwesig
schwerst unter druck ist wir haben das
in dem beitrag ja gerade eben auch
gesehen und sie sagte dann ja als
entschuldigung mit dem wissen von heute
hätte sie anders gehandelt nein diese
klimaschutz stiftung die anfang 20 21
gegründet wurde die war bewusst
gegründet worden um
sanktionsdrohungen der usa zu umgehen
das erklärte ziel dieser stiftung war
dass man firmen decken wollte die am bau
von nord stream 2 beteiligt waren damit
sie us-sanktionen
umgehen können bzw von us sanktionen
nicht belastet werden wir müssen einmal
uns in erinnerung rufen dass die usa
gesagt haben alle firmen die am bau
dieser pipeline
beteiligt werden es sind die werden mit
sanktionen belegt und genau das wollte
diese stiftung von manuela schwesig
umgehen verhindern also es war ein
bewusster tricks war ein bewusstes
austricksen unseres wichtigsten partners
nämlich der usa zugunsten wie wir jetzt
in auch eines kriegs treibers eines
kriegsverbrechers und darauf hätte man
schon zumindest anfang 20 21 kommen
können nicht dass putin ein
kriegstreiber ist wie er sich jetzt
darstellt aber dass er ein ganz ganz
gefährlicher
staatsführer ist ein diktator und dass
man mit ihm eigentlich keine geschäfte
machen darf nun sehen also im nachhinein
alle ein das nord stream 2 ein fehler
war gleichzeitig haben heute die
führenden wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute
in deutschland gesagt ein sofortiger
importstopp von russischem gas hätte
verheerende folgen für die deutsche
wirtschaft
220 milliarden euro würde das kosten
und da sehen wir doch was es bedeutet in
abhängigkeit von russland zu sein
deswegen ist das was manuela schwesig
was wir gerade im beitrag auch gesehen
haben dass dieses projekt nord stream 2
nicht nur in deutschen sondern in
westeuropäischen interesse gewesen ist
eine völlig völlig falsche einschätzung
war abhängigkeit von russland sehen wir
jetzt bedeutet das wenn wir uns davon
lösen wollen eine massive
wirtschaftskrise stürzen und das war
ehrlicher weise immer schon bekannt es
gab genug warnung auch wie bei bild
haben ja häufig genug in den vergangenen
jahren vor dem bau von moscheen zwei
gewarnt also da hat sich einfach manuela
schwesig da haben sich viele andere
einfach blind gestellt und die quittung
die wir dann bei einem gas embargo
tragen müssten die ist einfach extrem
bitter und wäre extrem hoch
einschätzungen von jan schäfer führen
dann gern